YOUR MORNING THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER. AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
PARTICIPATION. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ATER
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ON THE
OUTSIDE NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO DO IT THAT WAY YOU KNOW LIKE.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE ONE
FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR- I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM IT EXCEPT FOR
ONE MYSELF- DURING THE HEARING
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
RATHER CONNECTIONS MUTED FOR
TODAY'S HEARING- WE'LL HEAR FROM
MR VOCALLY PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE WITNESSES WE HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON THE TOPIC
OF TODAY'S AGENDA. TODAY WILL BE
HOLDING AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON TWENTY SEVEN MOST RECENT
EXTENSIONS TO THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE COP TAX. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE TWENTY SIX OF
THESE TRIBES HAVE AGREED TO AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH EXTENSION AND ONE
TOPPLING BAD A POMO INDIANS HAVE
AGREED TO A ONE YEAR EXTENSION.
MEMBERS A LIST OF THE TWENTY
SEVEN TRIBES CAN BE FOUND IN THE
COMPACT EITHER. SKEWS ME THE
COMPACT OVERVIEW DOCUMENTS INTO
FOLDERS. FOR THOSE OF YOU
UNFAMILIAR WITH SENATE PROCEDURE
THE ESTABLISHED POLICY ALLOWS
FOR AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE DETAILS OF THE COMPACT. TO
BE FOLLOWED BY A VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN HERE
TODAY. THE VEHICLE FOR
RATIFICATION FOR THESE CONTACTS
WILL BE S. B. EIGHT NINE EIGHT
BY YOURS TRULY. I BELIEVE MR
VOCALESE SENIOR ADVISER FOR THE
TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS FOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. IS HERE IN THE ROOM.
YEAH MISTER MOBILITY FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN SIR THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. RICHARD THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE
THIS MORNING AS WELL. I
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THESE NEW
AMENDMENTS EXTENDING CONTRACTS
THAT WERE SIGNED IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE AND TWO THOUSAND FOR
TWENTY SEVEN TRIBES. MY NAME'S
NATHAN VOCALLY ON THE SENIOR
ADVISER FOR TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS
FOR THE OFFICE OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING ALL THE TRIBES AND
THEIR CHAIRPERSONS HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENT ON AN EXTENSION TO
THEIR COMPACT I'D SPECIFICALLY
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRPERSONS
OF THOSE TRIBES. SIGNED COMPACTS
WITH THE STATE LAST YEAR AND HIS
INPUT HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL AND INSIGHTFUL FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND AGO
SHOOTING A REASONABLE TERM FOR
THESE EXTENSIONS. THERE CHAIR
MARY NORRIS OF THE QATAR TRY TO
LAYTONVILLE RANCHERIA CHAIR
ROBERT PINTO SENIOR AND WE HAVE
HIGH BAND OF KUMEYAAY INDIANS.
CHAIR JANET BILL MCKEON
RANCHERIA CHECK CHANCY INDIANS
CHAIR FUN MURPHY IN THE
RESIDENCY RANCHERIA. CHAIR
MELANIE RAFFIN AND WITH THE SURE
WOULD VALLEY RANCHERIA POMO
INDIANS ENSURE PARENTAL ABOUT
THE TABLE MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA.
LAST I JUST THE ONE EXTEND TO
THE CAR. FOR SANTA ROSA TO
RANCHERIA IN THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA SINCE THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S AGREED TO EXTEND THE
CONTACTS FOR TWENTY SEVEN
TRIBES. INCLUDING LINK THEIR
EXTENSIONS FOR THOSE. TWO TRIBES
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
THE CAMP OF END OF TWO COULD
DECLINE YOUR MISSION INDIANS AND
THE TABLE MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA.
TWENTY SIX OF THE TRIBES AGREED
TO AN EIGHTEEN MONTH EXTENSION
TO DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BY ONE TRIBE AGREED
TO A TWELVE MONTH EXTENSION. BY
WAY OF BACKGROUND IN TWO
THOUSAND PROP ONE A. GRANTED
TRIBES THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO
OPERATE SLOT MACHINES AND
BANKING AND PURCHASE SENATE'S
CARD GAMES IN CALIFORNIA. IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND THE STATE ENTERED INTO
OVER SIXTY TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACTS PURSUANT TO THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT. THESE
CONTACTS ARE GENERALLY REFERRED
TO AS THE NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CONTACTS. THEY WERE A FOR AN
INITIAL TWENTY YEAR TERM WITH
THE TERMINATION DATE OF DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
THEY'VE BEEN AUTOMATICALLY
EXTENDED AND NOW FIRE BY THEIR
OWN TERMS ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF
THIS YEAR. THE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE COMPACTS ALLOW THE STATE
AND TRIED TO AMEND THE TERM BY
MUTUAL AND WRITTEN AGREEMENT.
BUT EXTENSION IS NOT REQUIRED
UNDER THE CONTACT. THE MAJORITY
OF TRIBES WITH THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE CONTACTS HAVE SIGNED
NEW CONTACTS SINCE THEN. THE
TWENTY SEVEN TRIBES WITH
AMENDMENTS TODAY ARE ALL STILL
OPERATING UNDER THEIR NINETEEN
NINETY NINE COMCAST. AS I SAID
PREVIOUSLY WITH THE COMMITTEE
THE NEED FOR THESE EXTENSIONS
ARISE FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
INTERIORS ACTION IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO DISAPPROVE
THREE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACTS THAT THE ASSISTANT
SECRETARY FOR INDIAN AFFAIRS.
BUTTE IS ADDRESSING TOPICS
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT. THESE OF
THESE THIS APPROVALS MADE IT
APPARENT THAT THE STATE AND
THOSE REMAINING TRIBES WITH
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CONTACTS WE
NEED ADDITIONAL TIME TO
NEGOTIATE A NEW CONTACT. WITH
SUFFICIENT CONFIDENCE THAT THOSE
NEW CONTACTS COULD BE APPROVED
UNDER A GROW. AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE ALL TWENTY SEVEN TRIBES
HAVE AGREED TO AMENDMENTS
EXTENDING THEIR CONTACTS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
EXTENSIONS ARE FOR EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WITH ONE
TRIBE AGREEING TO A TWELVE MONTH
EXTENSION TO JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
LEGISLATORS RECENT RATIFICATION
OF CONTACTS FOR THE SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA IN THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA. SHOULD HELP TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE UNCERTAINTY
AROUND INTERIORS DOES APPROVALS.
I EXPECT THE THINGS WILL BE BACK
ON TRACK BY NOVEMBER OF THIS
YEAR NO BIGGER TO CONVERT THAT
INTO CONTACT CAN BE NEGOTIATED
WITH THOSE TRIBES INTERESTED IN
DOING SO. IT'S EXTENSIONS
FUNCTION AS AN AMENDMENT TO A
CONTACT FOR PURPOSES OF STATE
LAW. THEY WERE NEGOTIATED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND MUST BE RATIFIED BY
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
BECAUSE THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
ONLY TO EXTEND THE TERM OF THE
COMPACTS. UNDER FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THEY DO NOT REQUIRE
THE APPROVAL OF THE SECRETARY OF
THE DEPARTMENT BUT THEY DO STILL
HAVE TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT. THESE AMENDMENTS TO
EXTEND THE NINETY NINE CONTACTS
WOULD NOT PREVENT THE STATE
TRIES FROM MUTUALLY AGREEING TO
FURTHER EXTENSION SHOULD BE
NECESSARY. I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S TIME TODAY AND IF
YOU'D LIKE ME TO READ A LIST OF
THE TWENTY SEVEN TRIBES I'D BE
HAPPY TO DO SO I'LL ALSO REMAIN
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR VOCALLY UP BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC WANTED TO PARTICIPATE TO
CALL AND NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER 844-291-6364
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE. ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE. FOUR ZERO- WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK HERE TO THE
DAIS AND- MISERABLY THAT THERE
STILL SEEMS TO BE ONE TRIBE
THAT'S A NINETEEN NINETY NINE
COMPACT THAT IS YET TO REACH
AGREEMENT TO EXTEND THAT
COMPACT. IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
CAN TELL US ABOUT THAT AND WHY
AGREEMENT HAS NOT BEEN REGION IS
THAT TRIBE. CURRENTLY OPERATING
A CASINO YEAH ALL IT IS SO THAT
THEIR TRIBE THAT DOES NOT HAVE.
AN EXTENSION FOR THE NINETY NINE
NINE CONTRACTORS IN MANZANITA
BANDED DECLINE YOUR MISSION
INDIANS OF THE MANZANITA
RESERVATION. THEY ARE NOT
CURRENTLY GAMING I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT SPECIFICS RELATIVE TO THE
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND TRIED
THOSE ARE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL- SO
THAT TODAY AS OF TODAY WE DO NOT
HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH
UNANSWERED NEED A BATH. AND THEN
ONE OTHER QUESTION- ONE TRIBE.
WAS OKAY WITH THE TWELVE MONTHS
THE REST THE BALLOT HAD EIGHTEEN
MONTHS CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT WAS
THE REASON. FOR YEAH WHAT WHY
WOULD THEY NOT JUST TAKE THE
EXTRA SIX MONTH SUGGESTS APROPOS
OF NOTHING JUST. YEAH I I'M NOT
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THEIR SPECIFIC
REASONING OR OR ANY DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE TRIBE RELATIVE TO THAT- I
THINK THE COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DID EXTEND AN
EIGHTEEN MONTH IMITATION TO ALL
TRIBES. OKAY FAIR ENOUGH- WE'RE
NOT GONNA MOVE TO ANYBODY
WISHING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT-
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
POLITIQUE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALUSA INDIAN TRIBE ALONG WITH
THE CHIANG INDIAN TRIBE IN
WHOLEHEARTED C. SUPPORT OF THIS-
EXTENSION PERIOD IN ADDITION TO
THAT- I SEE SENATOR NIELSEN IS
COME IN. SO IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
AND EIGHTEEN BERKELEY ALONG WITH
YOUR STAFF AND WORKING WITH US-
THROUGH THIS. TOUGH FIGHT BUT
WE'RE GETTING CLOSER SO THANK
YOU THANK MISTREAT ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WISHING TO ADDRESS THE-
COMMITTEE. CITY NUMBER GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA.
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE TO CALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC INDIVIDUALLY AND WE
WILL CONTINUE. THANK YOU MISTER
IF YOU ARE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
QUICKLY UP GIVE YOU RELY NUMBER
OFFLINE IN THE PLACE YOU RIGHT
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO MY
FIFTEEN YOUR UP PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MCCORKLE FROM SOME OF THE
RANCHERIA. SB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SEVEN YOUR OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS OFF WITH THE
LOOT ON BEHALF OF CBS TRIED TO
LOOK LIKE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE AUTHOR FOR THE
HARTFORD WE CAN. GATHER WITH ALL
OF THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD THANK
YOU. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
EUROPE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THANKS
FOR DEEP PLEASE BY AT. ONE
FORTY. MICHAEL YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD AND HE
THANK YOU IS MIKE WILKINSON FIVE
SERVER C. NEGATIVE. UP IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. IF YOU.
FIVE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
KNOW I. FIVE THE MOMENT ARE
DETERMINED WILL BE RIGHT THERE.
THE TERM SYSTEM GROSGRAIN THREE
AFFECT YOUR DRIVING ORDER FTA.
NINETY EIGHT. BUT YOU'RE HERE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP THANK YOU MODERATOR- I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TODAY DO FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS- PUBLIC
TESTIMONY SPECIAL THANKS TO MR
VOCALLY FOR HIS WORK ON THESE
EXTENSIONS. IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
TO HANDLE IT SKEWS ME WHAT IT
WILL INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE FITIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY- THANKS. TO EVERYBODY
THAT'S HERE AND OUR STAFF- FOR
MAKING THIS ALL HAPPEN IN ALSO
MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR GUIDING
US THROUGH THIS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW. ADJOURNED
MISTER.